vous n'avez jamais essayé d'avoir
l'humour jacky
mais ça n'a pas marché non vous savez
l'humour c'est pas glamour faut faire
sans se regarder faire et moi je
m'écoutais c'était bien quand même
choqué c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui
est en train de jouer au golf il place
sa balle de golf il prépare son club et
au moment de taper dans la balle et il
tape tellement fort que la balle part
très très loin alors il court derrière
sa balle de golf il court il court il
court et ne voit plus à bâle alors une
voix un homme qui passe par là il lui
dit pardon monsieur ce que vous n'auriez
pas vu ma balle de golf et l'autre lui
répond qu'elle val d'orné vous aime bien
quand même chèque
[Musique]
alors crs bonsoir alors autant le dire
tout de suite
woods avait 85 ans oui je le connais
vous êtes d'une famille piémontaise qui
s'est installée à cogolin en 1800 vous
fait des petits j'ai fait des pipes
thomas toute votre vie voilà voilà
alors expliquez nous comment on fait des
pipes et d'abord pourquoi les filles de
cogolin sont meilleures que celles
d'ailleurs c'est un rapport à la bruyère
ah bon parce que la brière des morts qui
étaient bonnes pour faire les pipelines
à bord est douce et voilà un nordmann
ada bruyère que je vais vous demander ça
se trouve dans les formes et de l'avenir
comme on la traite quand on en trouve un
morceau comme ça mais voilà on l'a dans
la roche elle est pleine de petites
pierres c'est dans la terre on a des
roches
on a coupé comme ça ça fasse et des
bouchauds les bouchons ne fait bouillir
pendant 14 heures toute une nuit
pourquoi parce que ça tue tous les
petits verts qui peut y avoir dans la
terre et ensuite on était séché qu'à 35
ans ça dépend on ne le prévoyait pas
alors que cinq en or blanc des morceaux
bwana alors commencé à voir le bloc 10 -
tonna non c'est ça
là elle est presque terminé un manque
encore on compense le personne je peux
mettre le turbo
ils ont quoi le tuyau 1 et monique et on
fait toutes sortes de formes
maintenant ça c'est la chasse et bien
c'est la chasse c'est le monsieur thiam
qui me barbu quelques photos qui aiment
la fumée ça c'est la sherlock holmes est
votre préférée c'est vraiment notre prix
conseillé aux étudiants en saluant
plaisir au début ça c'est la poire ses
nerfs et jolies bottines courbet et puis
on a tous bien malgré le choc total et
résister si ça c'est la poire ça c'est
la pipe que le gros fumeurs fument à
voitures défilent en travaillant dans le
temps d'un après on appelait on appelait
la porte était menée dans la poche en a
après ya ça fait une grosse pub de
bureau comme vous voudriez quand on a
fumé arrêt je vous ai pas parlé de la
route de mystère et je la sers à sa
rivale cela dit elle ne se pose c'est la
pipe que finaliste al mana et puis après
vous avez la pico pas si vous voyez cela
on a cassé la croûte du bois regardez
style est belle pour conseiller les
fumeurs pendant six mois je me suis
excusé et m'a conté nous demandons de
notre mieux si vous les aimez droite
pour de longues pas pu et puis la
qualité si vous voulez le cinq trains de
son grain de sel à pipe flammes et c'est
le coeur de la racine
parce que la racine est comme ça au
milieu vous avez le père et de du coeur
c'est comme le coeur le corps humain et
par les veines et alors on a va tout les
plans de santé les bennes et après comme
qualité et aussi la bruyère qui fait
l'homme de perdrix c'est tout petit peu
comme ça c'est la bruyère très serré et
qui est très bonne et très douce aussi
le connaisseur le fumeur de pipe il
reconnu
vous avez toujours fait des livres
n'avait jamais eu envie de faire autre
chose en vie parce que j'aime le bois
c'est une joie des matières douces culte
chez vous ah non vous et quoi manger
police et au lycée et puis après je
vernis c'est parce qu'il y en a qui le
ronge
il y en a que des bonnes noires même un
moment donné c'était la loire les abris
et aujourd'hui les modes c'est quoi un
petit année vous avez commencé à
travailler à quel âge c'est curieux à 12
ans il faisait quoi conférer à 12 ans
vous savez on ramasse et les copeaux à
la couture on faisait passer des paliers
depuis peu d'une spirale des données
toute votre vie pour cette usine pour la
tamise courrier d'ailleurs j'ai vu marie
dès maintenant j'ai vu naître thierry le
fils toute ma famille je suis dans la
maison je suis en famille vous voyez
plus encore un peu de poil au mois
d'août quand ya des petits coups de feu
je vais poser là encore que ça va
continuer longtemps tout ça ouais ouais
si vous saviez depuis qu'ont été la
campagne anti tabac on demande plus de
peep toe jamais les grosses punaises et
bien le cumul à pitre échos le poiré
part on a des des plateaux que tous les
types de femmes
depuis la chine comme c'est joli alors
quand vous étiez plus jeune les gens se
moquent êtes vous en dix ans thérèse
elle fait des pipelines de vous dire
sans arrêt salduz et il me disait par le
directeur on a eut fait des
plaisanteries à la fabrique au magasin
quand j'en ai une cachette de la femme
les hommes ont même fait quelques
petites après pas plus que ça brûlait
c'était la clia les toitures de ne rien
rater de ligne youtube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu